welcome to this video Todd starts can't
start yeah that's a weird flag for the
sky Thailand may be on vacation or
something he's normally I think from
this is from Estonia I think okay
playing for Swedish okay Yuri krupin ski
well let's see I've got some English
opening here black has a wide choice
here b6 e 6g 65 yep one of those baby we
got yep we get a hedgehog I'm playing
with them inside fianchetto one of my
favorite lines
interesting way to play okay I'm going
to go for that after they capture this
night h4 so very typical motif yeah in
those Hedgehog or Queen's Indian type of
positions
he takes d5 Knight h4 let's see like
very often goes for a 5 if he gets to
this position yeah let's see I'm
threatening here to play Knight f5
mostly aha so he's covering this ok the
question is if I really want to allow my
CAPTCHA on h4 which will happen if I
take with the night and I takes night
eggs and he will take h4 so I will take
with the pawn and
hmm
yeah why can I not take I don't don't
see it ready of course he has some
tactical ideas but at the end I should
be should be just better okay
here I have Knight c3 as a possibility
or also just the capture takes takes
take on D fire this is just good for
White Knight takes Queen takes Bishop h4
I can take on d6 yeah oh here I can play
Knight f5 whether with a nice position I
think or not yeah I guess so yeah that's
just nice for white I'm not even a pawn
down and it almost looks like a position
where you would have good compensation
okay so hmm
just keep it simple approach with this
just winning this pawn hard for him to
to not lose it
and if the porn gets lost with 96 there
is 94 or also around the corner with the
fantastic night position that is a very
harmonious he wants to take them yeah I
mean if I play something like rookie -
there might be c4 I am
yeah well they're there this more than
one one good way to play yeah but I'm
not sure what to do exactly hmm my in
Queen d2 is good right okay let's let's
grab this it should be should be very
nice for white
maybe I should have thought about that I
mean I thought I have this move but
something I should have considered a bit
more carefully I can just take this rook
I mean there's really no reason not to
take it okay now what is the the easiest
way probably taking a seven
he cannot miss the sepal again he cannot
move the c-pawn but yeah but still I
should take it
yeah and this is just an exchange black
resilience yeah yeah that's pretty easy
right he's no he's got no counter play
and I will be easily activating my rooks
yeah that was a really bad position out
of the opening I mean this is already
quite comfortable for white but okay and
I really don't don't know if this beef
is really something I was thinking that
something like this should be done just
preventing the knight from jumping to f5
and then we have a fairly normal
position it looks a little bit like a
fianchetto Benoni
with the bishop on g2 but okay blacks
bishops are both misplaced for a Benoni
tricky position okay and here I think I
can really just take bishop cheeks you
have the computer even points out 9066
but this is also quite good yeah it
gives gives wider launch advantage in
steaks yeah okay this is the the keep it
keep it simple approach just take
everything
yeah maybe here I can improve some
somehow because it really looks very
promising and there might be ideas to to
use this offside rook the computer wants
to play Quincy for him now it might be
an idea but this is probably not much
worse now I'm threatening a five and
this is answered by before and now
really like s is totally in trouble and
this is threatened this is threatened
probably blackest it's toast
the computer already wants to check on
f2 which shows that like it's pretty
much busted yeah and he just gave away
the rook yeah this was a live an opening
catastrophe but glad to have won this
thanks for watching